do you think a one-game suspension is
granted for something like that for
dream on the Golden State Warriors
they're facing Cavs okay
and it's the season where they went 73
and 9 and the whole draymond Green
situation that took place when you watch
that ok they call the foul I get it
let's say fouls their technical foul
fine do you think a one-game suspension
is granted for something like that for
draymond
like why did they suspend him for a game
in the finals I think it depends on who
was up and down in the series
I think if Golden State would have been
down in the series there would have been
no suspension but it you know if they're
up in the series there's a suspension
why because it takes a good player away
off the floor and then it allows for the
series to go on a little bit further it
allows for Cleveland to win a game you
know I just think it's a situation where
you have to look at it from a experience
and referee perspective of what referees
are doing on the floor who they're
talking to
during timeouts before the game who
they're laughs and well you know and all
that from a perception wise other
referees you know we'll pick that up
because they know maybe this guy's you
know getting in a position to try and
get a call you know other players will
look over and see why is he talking in
that kind yes not talking to me an owner
or a coach will look over to timeout and
see why is he talking that guy not
talking to me and then what happens
after that
series in the next couple times down the
floor did they get a call do you go back
to why he got that call did he because
he had conversation with them you
there's just a lot of things that you
have to look at